last night as America really did for a
moment seemed on the brink of war with
Iran some users on Twitter voice their
displeasure by tweeting the hashtag I
voted for Hillary it was a nice little
rhetorical win until Hillary Clinton
herself had to join in the message of
course is that president Hillary would
not be starting a war with Iran was that
true or would Hillary Clinton be maybe
the single most likely person in the
history of America to start a war with
Iran remember as Secretary of State she
bragged about overthrowing Muammar
Gaddafi in Libya how'd that work well
they they're now selling slaves in
downtown Tripoli watch that is the land
of unconfirmed entities we Came we saw
he died we killed killing people's all
areas especially in that country's fall
apart and slave markets open
anyway if anything Hillary Clinton's
intentions toward Iran or even more
bloodthirsty in 2008 which was a long
time ago the first time she's running
for president she warned that Iran had
better be ready because she was going to
crush them if Iran were to launch a
nuclear attack on Israel what would our
response be and I want the Iranians to
know that if I'm the president we will
attack Iran whatever stage of
development they might be in their
nuclear weapons program in the next ten
years during which they might foolishly
consider launching an attack on Israel
we would be able to totally obliterate
them yeah so just in case you didn't
remember that Hillary Clinton was the
neocon cuz she was and is there you go
one person who may remember is
congressman a Democratic presidential
candidate Tulsi Gabbard she was a sunset
tonight come thanks so much for coming
on so whatever you think of Hillary and
Ike you know I think she's capable in
certain ways I'm not I think everything
about her is bad but kind of a
full-blown neocon know or am i imagining
that no you know no matter I think I
think everybody knows and understands
that she is a war monger and
is her record that that is proof of
totally right I love that phrase you
showed the clip about Libya yeah look to
her influence on going to launch a
regime change war in Syria Libya you
look throughout obviously her support
for the war in Iraq throughout her
history her track record is well known
and I think this is why a lot of people
back in 2016 in the general election
decided that they would vote for Trump
because of what he was saying on the
campaign trail about ending stupid Wars
and bringing our troops home the problem
now though is and I'm out on the
campaign trail and hearing from a lot of
people who had voted for Trump largely
because of this issue and and their
concern about how rather than ending
stupid Wars and bringing our troops home
what they're seeing is more of our
troops being deployed to the Middle East
and now us our country at war with with
Iran's they're coming and saying hey
Dulce we're confident that you as
president commander-in-chief will
actually and these long-standing reason
so what should we and I think you make
it entirely you make a fair point
so what should we do going forward so we
opened the show with a call for a
complete withdrawal from ROK yeah you
serve there yeah the US Army I'm the
only candidate running for president who
served in uniform in Iraq and so what
understand below very clearly the
situation there and yes for days now
I've been calling for our troops from
Iraq and Syria to come home and here's
why when we deploy our troops down rage
when they're in harm's way there has to
be a very clear mission that's
achievable or they know exactly what
they're doing there and why and that
that mission actually serves our
country's national security interests
yes but that's not what's happening
right now I think in Iraq especially we
see how our troops are there their
mission there they were supposed to be
there to prevent a resurgence of Isis
and al Qaeda but that's not what's
happening now with with the US commander
in Iraq announcing a couple of days ago
that our US troops will no longer be
putting any efforts towards preventing
al-qaeda and Isis from mounting a
resurgence because they will have to
dedicate all of their resources and
efforts towards mounting a defensive
posture against Iranian forces and
Iranian backs okay I mean I'm not
endorsing Iran obvious course not
but just in point of fact because facts
do matter yes in 2020 wasn't Iran one of
the forces that overcame Isis am i met
working yes and and in Iraq there was
this this kind of long-standing uneasy
alliance between US forces Iraqi
government forces Iranian and
iranian-backed Shia militias and the
Kurds they're all coming together to
defeat and prevent a resurgence of Isis
and al-qaeda and this is where
unfortunately president Trump's actions
are actually undermining our national
security in two important ways that
because our troops are no longer being
able to focus on that mission of
preventing Isis from getting a
resurgence it's creating an opening for
Isis and al-qaeda to reconstitute
themselves and to pose a threat to our
forces to our country and the people in
the region and secondly Iran is now as
they've announced they're no longer
complying with any restrictions that
were in the Iran nuclear agreement
speeding quickly towards developing
their own nuclear weapons capability
which puts us at greater risk and puts
our partners and allies in the world at
risk getting out of Iraq would be and
here's why this is so for getting out
getting our troops out of Iraq and Syria
is essential because the longer that
they are there the more likely it is
that they are at risk and that we will
end up in this endless tit-for-tat
back-and-forth quagmire of a war with
people wondering what is it all for
exactly what are we training our troops
or hostages and we owe them more than
that absolutely
congressman thank you thank you